hello everyone and welcome to another
really wild game from round nine of the
2021 tata steel masters
edition uh in a game between narada
slavotoshek and fabiano caruana and
this game features a certain move that
uh has been discussed
a lot as it um uh well it's not
something
you would expect anyone to play but in
this game uh world number two fabiano
kirwana plays it
uh so let's see what's that all about so
uh voitershek opens with
c4 he goes for the english opening we
have knight to f6
knight to f3 and d6 we have d4 and
g6 now uh knights the c3 bishop to g7
and now
even though we've opened up with the
english with e4 we transpose into the
king's indian defense
we have castles by fabi and bishop to e2
we have
e5 now striking in the center so all
fairly standard stuff we have castles by
white
and now fabi goes for bishop to g4 and
bishop to g4 is a move that
no no one plays here knight to c6 is the
standard idea here there are over 18 000
games in the
in the database where knight to c6 is
played in this position but fabi goes
for bishop to g4
uh because he has a very specific idea
here so
let's see what happens here bishop to e3
uh
you don't kick away the bishop right
away with h3 because that's
what black would want to after he
captures on d4 and queen captures
then he gets some nice development in
with knight to c6 as black will use the
the queen on d4 to develop the knight
for free so instead after bishop to g4
we have bishop to e3
and now bishop captures on f3 bishop
captures and e
captures on b4 now comes bishop captures
on d4
and now knight to c6 now challenging the
bishop
bishop back to e3 and now there is one
game in the database from 1998 where
knight the d7 was played but here fabi
goes rook to e8
and it is as of move 11 that we have a
completely new game
uh so uh uh the the four point is
pressure twice but it's also defended
twice so
another problem there uh queen to d2
uh radic uh develops the queen connects
rooks as we
uh or sometimes say on this channel uh
they they become bros for life uh as was
uh for uh
the the the term was coined in last
year's spock champs i believe
uh knight to d7 now by fabi and rook
eight to d1 and this is the position
from the thumbnail and the position
everyone was weirded
weirded out about because here fabi
played bishop
captures on c3 and this is really weird
because
if you look at this position and you ask
yourself what
is black's most powerful piece in this
position
everyone will say it's of course the
dark square bishop look at how beautiful
the bishop is it's uh
you know cutting the entire board in
half like
we would we would likely give up a rook
to keep this bishop alive but here
fabi played bishop captures on c3 and
it's something that
a lot of players would characterize as
an anti-positional move
uh but nowadays um you know as we do
have chess engines
the word anti-positional in chess kind
of kind of lost meaning because today
you can play everything it doesn't
matter how ugly it looks uh if the
engine says it's okay you can prepare it
and you can play it in here
uh fabi makes such a move bishop
captures on c3
queen captures no reason to ruin your
pawn structure so queen captures and now
queen to f6 immediately fabi goes after
the queen trade
and um now that you've traded off the
uh the dark square bishop for night you
kind of want to use the dark squares for
attacking purposes and
you're not really interested in trading
queens here so queen back to c1
and now knight to c5 getting knight the
knight to that a very nice square
the knight controls the b4 square so for
the moment b4 is not
a possibility yet but now queen to b1
adding another defender to the e4 pawn
as now you
have to do that and also preparing b4 in
some lines
so queen to e6 and now radik doesn't go
for b4 right away he goes
rook f2 e1 saying that uh okay even
though you're attacking this three times
there will be some discoveries uh if you
if you go for some characters
so here instead fabi goes for queen
captures on c4
grabbing that pawn and now b3 here radik
is preparing
bishop back to c1 to b2 to grab hold of
this diagonal
so queen to c3 we have bishop to d2 now
comes bishop
queen back to f6 and now bishop to c1
and now
finally this bishop will grab hold of
this beautiful diagonal we have
h5 by fabi not worried about that one
bit
bishop to b2 and now knight to e5 and
this is
uh fabi's plan now he says okay i have a
monster night here and
you're not going to be able to move it
uh you're not going to be able to move
it unless you want to give up your uh
dark square bishop but if you give up
your dark square bishop that's like the
only
good thing you have in the position so
here bishop back to e2
and now fabi continues pushing with h4
and what do you play here well there
aren't all that many moves for white
here so
uh radik prepares queen to c1 he grabs
hold of the f4 square he wants to play
f4 kick away that knight and of course
uh well not not kick away
the knight just to win it because the
knight will not be able to move
so fabi plays g5 he blocks the f4 pawn
and now comes bishop to b5 and now
this was most likely the critical moment
of the game where
radic could have gone for some serious
counter play with the move b4 but it's a
very long line very hard to spot uh b4
attacks the knight 96 and now bishop to
g4
made possible because the knight cannot
move it's pinned and now
after queen to f4 uh we capture an e5
bishop captures queen captures rook
captures and now after pawn captures
you're gonna capture an e6 remove the
defender of the c
pawn captures and now captures and we
have a we have an equal end game with
both players having two rooks and six
pawns so uh ideas like uh these are in
the position but it's uh
very very hard to spot of course and
especially if you're playing fabi
uh world number two you know that he has
all of this prepared probably it's
probably not even good
so why even waste time they are
calculating it so here we have bishop to
b5 instead
attacking the rook here rook to e7 and
now
rook to e3 just getting uh getting that
rook
uh uh up to the third rank to help out
with the defense
uh but other than that there aren't all
that many many great moves like we said
for white
queen to g6 now again putting more
pressure on the pawn here
preparing rook the other rook to come
into the game once you kick away the
slight square bishop
and here bishop back to e2 so uh
white wants to play f3 and he wants to
keep an eye on that
g4 square we have rook 888 by fabi and
now
queen to c2 so what can you do here you
can just wait and see what black will
play
knight to e6 and now finally f3 and now
you don't have to worry about this pawn
being captured
but other than that your position is is
shaky at best here we have knight to f4
by fabi
uh and the bishop back to f1 so adding
another defender to the pawn here
we have c6 now preparing d5 and now
queen to f2 and here rook to e6 just
adding another defender here
we have rook to c3 not a lot of active
moves for white you have to play
something rook to c3 and now
fabi finally breaks through with d5
uh and now what do you play here here uh
radik went for g3 and it seems like a
very reasonable move because after
captures and captures what was played in
the game
once the knight moves it's a it's a
pretty good position for
uh for white however here fabi plays d
captures on e4
and now there's a problem because what
do you do here
here g captures on f4 was played but
this is a terrible move
uh what you want to do here is actually
capture this pawn
because now the knight kind of needs to
move and after the knight moves
now you can try and defend a little bit
with rook to c5 but it's a
again a disc a disgusting engine defense
line
uh that i'm only showing because i know
how much you guys enjoy them for example
knight g4
attacks the queen queen to b2 and now as
this is being threatened you don't want
to allow rook captures this uh knight
has to block
and now you can just go bishop to g2 and
you've consolidated a little bit
knight captures on g3 you can now go
bishop captures
rook captures you can go rook captures
and after rook captures
finally you get queen to d8 with check
uh
if you go here then uh a lot of things
are possible you can bring the rook to
d6 if the king moves to h7
then let's say rook the d7 and it's uh
it's a pretty crazy position
black is of course better but uh white
is at least fighting
uh however after d captures on e4 eradic
did not go for this he said all right
either this works or it doesn't but now
comes g captures on f4 with a discovered
check
and i think it was around this point
that peter liko said that the position
is
uh he's so lost it's hard to say
anything
and that it that is in fact true because
what do you play here
uh here queen to g2 blocking uh check
and also
uh trading uh for forcing a queen trade
uh but now comes
e captures on f3 and now you cannot
capture the pawn because it's defended
by the knight so you have to trade
queens here
captures we have rook captures with
check and now king to h1
and now fabi goes f2 so what do you play
rook to g1 is coming then the other rook
can come for example
uh well to h6 uh but a lot of other
checkmating patterns are possible
so here bishop the h3 was played by
radik but now
the position is still completely lost uh
feel free to pause the video here and
win the game for fabi in in the quickest
way possible while i give you a couple
of seconds
so uh for those of you who are able to
do it congratulations on spotting
the uh hard moved spot and for those of
you who just want to enjoy the show it's
knight to c4 this is just a a beautiful
idea
attacking the bishop the bishop is
undefended but also going for
rook to e1 check and there is no way for
you to defend against
both of these threats so here in the
game rook captures on c4 was played but
now
fabi just played rook to e1 with check
and he was in this position on
39 just before reaching time control
that fabiano corona won the game or
rather uh
radoslav resigned in the game uh why do
you resign here
well you either lose lose a whole rook
uh or you capture it and then you're
just getting checkmated
you bring the queen into the game and
now whatever you play let's take
h2 queen to g1 will be checkmate
so yeah after queen to e1 radic resigned
and a wonderful victory for fabiana
corona
who may or may not have joined the
leaders of the tournament but we're
going to show one more game that was
decisive from round nine uh anish geary
versus maxime vasher lagrave
uh and only then we will show the
standings so uh prepare for one more
game but i'm probably going to upload
that one
uh you know tomorrow morning uh so yeah
that's the game hope you guys enjoyed it
and that you uh
now see that even though uh at some
point in the in chess history
uh moves like bishop captures and c3
would have been considered
extremely anti-positional if you played
this like if you were a grand master i
don't know
uh some 50 years ago and let's say
between it saw you play this he'd be
like oh you know
this person should never play chess
again i mean that you do not play that
uh but nowadays with the appearance of
chess engines absolutely everything is
possible
uh so i always you know think outside of
the box and you know engines are our
friends uh whether we like it or not
uh so that's the game hope you guys
enjoyed it uh i would like to thank
alejo alluralde
henry mortensen for contribution to my
channel thank you a lot i really
appreciate it
as usual you can check to my previous
videos here thank you for watching and
i will see you soon continuing the
coverage of the tata still 2021
checking up on your wonderful
suggestions and whatever else happens in
the chess world
thank you i will see you soon and have
an excellent rest of your day